well joining us now is the concept of
security Minister Brandon Lewis thank
you for being with us today
Kean of course to talk about your offer
on immigration policy but first I just
want to address the Prince Andrew
interview I'm not sure if you've seen
the whole interview but what have you
made of what you have seen well I
haven't seen the whole interview
actually I saw some of the clips were
allowed out you know in advance but I
think it's government Minister
commenting on anything to the royal
families not particularly productive
particularly when I haven't seen the
whole interview I think the royal family
as a whole of something personal I'm
quite proud of I think as a country they
do us a huge amount of good we got
amazing person as a as the queen of
doing amazing work for our country all
the time actually put forwarding our
values around the world and actually I
think it's a great testament to what we
stand for as a British nation you're
clearly a someone who believes in the
royal family but at the same time if you
look at what's happened with Prince
Andrew he must be concerned that this is
damaging the royal family I mean he said
in the interview he didn't regret his
friendship with a convicted sex offender
because the opportunities he got from it
were useful he said that he went to stay
with epstein after he was erased from
jail because he was too honorable I mean
many people watching this feel he should
have shown more concern for the victims
I can understand now I haven't say I
haven't seen the interview so I think to
comment something I haven't seen is
difficult as you say quality I make no
apologies that I think Prince Charles
the Queen the whole of the world family
I think are a great asset for our
country and we all want to see them in a
very very positive light ok ok now you
of course are here cuz you won't talk
about your immigration announcement what
exactly is it that the Conservatives are
proposing well we've set out this week a
few things first of all we will reduce
immigration because when we leave the
European Union we will then pass an
immigration Act that brings in a
points-based system what we've also
outlining today actually is that we are
going to also restrict benefits so that
when people come over from the European
Union they will have to wait like
everybody else a fair and equal system
with the entire world wait five years
before they can get access to benefits
so it's a much fairer system for
everybody both a British taxpayer but
also people equally and fairly around
the world it's interesting you're
emphasizing the fairness that that you
want to be treating migrants in the same
way if they come from the EU are outside
of the EU so does that mean you're
leveling up for everybody or are you
leveling down because
at the minute of course if you're an EU
migrant then it's easy if you come here
and you have access to more service
intellicus yeah I think we have to
recognize that when you go around the
country is a large parts of the country
where people understandably have been
frustrated for many years that people
can come here from the EU never having
contributed to the economy and have
pretty much immediate access to benefits
what we're saying is we're going to put
that why we wanted to do this at some
time but you can only do this once
you've left the European Union and we've
also been quite consistent around saying
when we leave the European Union we want
to have a migration system I mean
immigration system but is equal and fair
from around the world it's down I would
argue it's about fairness it is about
saying wherever you come from in the
world it's not about geography if you're
coming to this countries about what you
contribute to our economy into our
communities but it's about fairness and
treating people equally but it's pretty
clear the EU citizens rights and
benefits access for example are being
leveled down to the level of gnarnia
systems everything up oh no we are we
are saying to people if you come from
the European Union you'll be treated
like everybody from anywhere else around
the world that once we've left you will
have to wait five years for access to
benefits I just would like to clarify
though anybody who's already here and is
part of the EU set of status scheme
their rights are protected they are
absolutely clearly protected and in
place this will be for new people coming
from the EU once we've left the European
Union under a future immigration system
you're kind of emphasizing the changes
to benefits but it's important to point
out isn't it that actually EU migrants
EU workers are positive contributors to
the public finances because they end up
paying more in taxes and they take out
when it comes to services and benefits
actually unlike migrants from outside of
the EU and actually unlike people who
were born in the UK so are you going
after the wrong people here no this is
again I think this is absolutely fits
with that kind of methodology what we're
saying is when people first come to this
country like any UK system actually
you've contributed through your life to
that benefit system through the taxes
that we all pay and what we're saying
for the EU citizens after we've left the
European Union when they come they will
be in the same position like the rest of
the world after five years they'll have
access but that gives five years to be
able to contribute to our economy in a
way that anybody else would do and I
think that is a fair system not just to
entire world but to the British taxpayer
as well I'm interested to know when this
is coming in
because I can't help but think you know
you want to strike an ambitious trade
with the EU next year Boris Johnson does
want to extend the transition if you are
in government now this if any we know
that in any trade deal one of the first
things that's on the table will be how
migrants are treated and this is going
to be the sort of thing that is going to
be up for discussion in a trade deal so
is this policy really worth of paper
it's written on because it could be the
first thing that goes out the window in
these trade discussions
well actually this policy is a really
good example of why we need a good
strong clear conservative majority
because it's only with a conservative
majority that first we can get break see
done so one would it come in and winning
January 2021 so what we're doing this
what we're saying is first we need to
get brakes it done only a conservative
majority can deliver that that's the
difference between us and labor at the
moment
once we've got a conservative majority
we even left the EU we will be passing
an immigration bill that immigration
bill will include the points based
system a new immigration system and
these changes in terms of how we deal
with benefits all of which will come
into force in January 2021 when we've
left the EU at the end of any
implementation period but only
conservative majority can deliver that
anything else we're going to have
another couple of referendums and labour
then arguing and campaigning against
what they've campaign for themselves in
that bizarre situation they've got we're
very clear we will get breaks it done by
the end of January we'll implement an
immigration bill and this will come into
force I'm just skeptical if that your
timetable is right given the fact that
this is going to be happening after a
trade deal is struck given the time only
that of course because preferential
access for citizens will be one of the
first things on the table when you're
negotiating that trade oh I would say
there's no need to be skeptical that
people were skeptical that the Prime
Minister could renegotiate the
withdrawal agreement open it up and get
it done he got that done in under 90
days and we've got a deal a deal that a
conservative majority can pass but we've
got to work hard to get that majority
and then we can pass an immigration bill
we will have left the EU will have a new
fresh fair immigration system and it
probably one that brings back control
where the British government controls
who's coming into that country so when
people are thinking about who they want
to vote for in this election would a
Conservative government bring
immigration up or down I mean okay so
see government with this system will
bring immigration down by how much we're
not set an arbitrary targets not getting
into those kind of issues that we've had
or what we're saying is just in case you
miss something yeah it's been very
framed I think one of the frustrations
people have had and I've had when I was
doing immigration for a few months my
selfies with these kind of arbitrary
targets when you're still in the EU if
freedom of movement
you just can't meet them and I think
that's why people understandably have
become very frustrated I think people
want to see that we've got control this
gives us back control by getting control
and using the migration Advisory
Committee to ensure the people come here
ones who contribute to our economy we
can also ensure that immigration will
fall under conservative government but
we need a conservative majority to do
that okay now there are reports today
that the Home Secretary Priti Patel
blocked a recent rescue attempt to try
and bring back unaccompanied children
and orphans from Syria is that right
well going to be slightly cautious at
how else this you have to excuse me but
I'm not going to divulge your leak
what's in a newspaper leaked of a
National Security Council meeting but I
do not recognize a situation where I'm
aware of at any point the Home Secretary
blocking any kind of rescue mission what
we've always said is with the children
who are caught up in conflict we will
look at them on a case-by-case basis to
sure we're doing the right thing by
those children and their families and we
will continue to do that you can see why
people might listen to what you're
saying there and saying like British
children elephants in a war zone will
look at them on a case-by-case basis
no it's about looking and making sure we
do what's right for those children
what's right for the safety and security
of the children their families and of
course our own forces who would be
involved in any situation like this but
we do make sure we look at it on a
case-by-case basis and we make the right
decision for everybody involved are they
a security risk these children well I'm
not gonna comment on particular security
issues a phone meshes matter national
security I think will be inappropriate
it's coming it but we do looking on a
case-by-case basis and when I talk about
security which are it's not just about
whether there are national security is
the safety and security of the child
itself as well okay okay now move you on
to other issues because there's been
claims this week that the Conservative
Party members within that group have
been offering jobs or peerages to
members of the brexit party if they
stand down now I spoke to a benebabe a
brexit Party MEP yesterday this is what
he said to me he cited the case of Ann
Widdecombe and then he went on to say I
know they've been lots
conversations going on they as in the
Conservative Party are being economical
with the truth absolutely it's been
going on without a shadow of a doubt
happiest conversations been happening we
have not offered any deals to anybody I
think what's rather surreal with this
conversation not least of all is the
fact that actually as chairman I'm the
person removed down when it comes
membership of the Conservative Party
because she had joined the British apart
yet it's completely in breach of our
Constitution but also because we are the
party of so we need to get a clear
conservative majority we are fighting
these seeds to get breaks it down and
deliver for people what's slightly
bizarre with this whole conversation is
this is in light of a situation where in
contrast we're seeing the Liberal Party
with lots of small PI's even labour
talking about restricting choice for
people open and we're being open about
that we are not doing that we are not
offering nobody's been offered jobs or
anything like that we all these
conversations been going we are
absolutely focused I mean conservative
candidates in all of these seats and
saying to people very clearly to get
bricks it done to get on to moving on to
a domestic agenda exciting domestic
agenda we've got investing you know NHS
in our schools in our police we need a
conservative majority the only way to do
that is to vote conservative so you can
guarantee that there had been no
conversations that have been going on
we've been offering jobs to brexit party
members or candidates there's been no
job offers we're not doing deals with
anybody we've been very clear about this
in the beginning the plan is very very
clear about this as well we are focus on
having conservative candidates and
seeking for people to vote for those
candidates not doing deals with people
voting conservatives we get a
conservative majority it's the only way
to get breaks down the see our country
unleashes potentially have any
conversations been going on I'm not
aware of any conversations going on
there's no deals being done we are
fielding conservative candidates as none
on nation papers that have been
published already show across the
country we are the one true national
party that can get a majority get break
see done and deliver for our economy and
our country so Ann Widdecombe been Habib
they're just making up and I don't
recognize that I taught as I say this is
somebody who actually removed down when
it comes membership of the party because
she's now a member the brakes a party we
are focused on getting conservatives
elected that's the only way we move our
country fought and stops Corbin and the
chaos of two referendums and what Labour
offer next year okay and I'm keen to
talk about a couple of issues now
related to your security brief
firstly about brexit and because there's
been a bit of confusion about whether or
not under the brexit deal that Boris
Johnson is putting forward businesses in
Northern Ireland would have to face
additional bureaucracy additional costs
when exporting to the rest of the UK now
if there is any sense that the Union is
being undermined there is of course a
risk isn't there that unionists could
protest there could even be violence is
this something that you are concerned
about
well obviously nobody wants to see any
kind of violence so I'm rest of course
anywhere in the UK at least of all
obviously in Northern Ireland and I
think we've got a deal that does work it
delivers it brings the whole of the UK
into a one clear customs union that's a
United Kingdom customs union that's what
we promise to do it's what the Prime
Minister's delivered do you think that
there will be additional bureaucracy or
cheques the businesses exporting to the
rest of the UK
obviously there are customs checks at
the moment in the current structure that
we've got so there is some there were
some checks that we already do but as we
go forward the whole point of the deal
that the Prime Minister's negotiated he
can when we get through that
implementation peer with a future trade
agreement is one that means we can have
good fluid trade across United Kingdom
without bears there's no no art no
question of a border anywhere we want to
keep one clear United Kingdom and one
that trade positively with the rest of
the world and indeed our partners in
Europe Michael Gove said yesterday that
there would be administrative processes
for those businesses and he's right
isn't it but there are already
administrative process well what we're
working on is making sure that when we
get our future Trade Agreement we've got
a good free-flowing trade with all our
partners around the world including
those in the EU but we're not gonna be
having borders we're going to have one
customs union for the whole of the
United Kingdom so it's smooth I'm
interested in this sort of security
implications of this and one so called
looting loyalist was quoted in The Times
last month saying if there is a proposal
to align Northern Ireland for the south
or one a border down the Irish Sea we'd
have no option but to take to the
streets where that goes afterwards is
anyone's guess Noorie lists will not
roll over neatly our Security Minister
is there as an increased security risk
as a result if there breaks that dough
that Boris Johnson negotiated no I don't
believe there was a torn I'll go further
actually as someone who's been chairman
of the conservative and unionist party I
believe passionately in the United
Kingdom being one single United Kingdom
and that's what this deal does deliver
so you're not concerned
any additional security risks well I'm
always concerned about security risk
around the whole of the UK for a whole
range of reasons as well I think it's so
we're so 40 have such amazing people
working in our security services and in
our police and the PS and I who keep us
safe every day this deal is a good deal
for the United Kingdom one that keeps it
as a United Kingdom and keeps trade
flowing smoothly around the United
Kingdom in itself okay now while we're
talking about security and why was it
that the government didn't decide to
publish the report by the Intelligence
and Security Committee into potential
Russian involvement in democracy ahead
of the election well we will publish the
report but these reports do go through
them it's a lengthy report they go
through proper processes pretty much in
line with every other report in the last
few years four to six weeks that's not
unusual
we want to make sure when a particularly
national security is involved we go
through that process properly and
thoroughly and when that's done and
obviously the perder for the general
election which means we can't publish
things do in a generation will slow that
slightly but ask the GM election that
report will be published everyone
understands that it's ready to go while
hasn't already been published that's
really important there's a difference
between what the rumors say around what
may be ready to publish we we have to go
through a proper thing you're saying
it's not ready to get we have to go
through a complete and proper process
particular matter national security it
is quite common I think the average is
four to six weeks these kind of
documents to come through before they're
published we're well within the realms
of that allowing for perd of the German
election and it will be published an
open democracy investigations found that
the Conservative Party has received
significant amounts of money donations
from Russian individuals we can just
have a look at Ben Bradshaw of the
Labour MP he said this now we know one
of the reasons Boris Johnson is
suppressing the official report into
Kremlin penetration of our democracy is
because of the substantial and growing
links between Russian money and the
Conservative Party is that true
I think it's hypocritical beyond belief
first of all we're talking about British
citizens any donations go through full
legal process and due diligence and our
proper donations and they're from
British citizens and we should not
prevent British citizens take it and
play in their full part in British
political life but coming from a party
whose leader started with Russia over
the United Kingdom the intelligence
agencies when we had that tragedy in
Salisbury I find that pretty despicable
way to play politics the way to really
addresses though will be just a
published report wouldn't it well all of
the donations the Conservative Party are
published they're done by the natural
commission they're completely
transparent but again people bills with
phones who are British and citizens I
think he needs to look to his own leader
and the fact that he sizes our enemies
like Russia against the UK and our
national security
pretty much it seems every chance he
gets that's a party I don't trust on
Russia okay thank you very much for
coming on the program today thank you